[Music]
Hey, what's up? How's everybody doing?
Welcome to my channel, Mike's
Automotive. So, today we're working with
the Honda Civic, you guys. And this is
like 2016 and up for push to start. Now,
the customer had a auto universal remote
pro into the vehicle.
And the thing is that it was kind of
working. It turns on the car when it
wants to. It doesn't turn on. Sometimes
it does. So, she's like, "Hey, I'm just
going to get an OEM smart key and just
go ahead and program it." So, I said,
"All right." So, we're going to be using
our auto. Go ahead and make sure you
have your uh emergency lights on if you
can't turn it on. If you can turn it on,
turn it on. Okay. Now, um we're going to
go to automatic uh VIN scan. So, it's
going to automatically search for the
vehicle using the VIN. Um like I said,
if you can turn it on, turn it on. We're
going to select smart key.
We're going to do a push to start. Okay?
Because it's push to start.
Um, as you guys can see, there's
information right there for Civic.
Um, we're going to We always go through
MMO status scan just because it it does
the the scan of the MMO system and it
lets us know something's wrong with it
um or anything. So, it says is ignition
turned on by pressing the start button.
If you can turn it on, yes. If you can
press no.
So, um, we're going to go ahead and scan
it. You guys can see it has the smart
system on here and then the immo system.
So, the smart system would be like
anything that's keyless, any modules
that are that can pick it up, you know,
the immo system, of course, is the
immobilizer system that immobilizes a
vehicle if it's not the correct key. So,
um, we're going to go through all keys
lost. Actually, if you have a key, you
can go through add a key, but I'm going
to go through all keys lost because at
the end of the day, their key didn't
want to turn on the car and off when it
needed to. And this requires you to turn
on and off the car. So, it says to place
the key to be learned in the vehicle and
take all the other keys out.
Is the ignition turned on by pressing
on? Um, no. We can't turn it on. So,
we're going to press no. It says press
and hold the start button. So, we're
going to press and hold the start button
until the until the ignition uh turns on
and the cluster turns on and all the
lights, everything kind of like
accessory mode.
Um, is ignition switched on? Please
release the ignition. We're going to
press okay.
[Music]
Okay, here's the next step. whether it's
a newer model generally refers to after
2020. We're going to press no because
it's not over 2020. It's like 16 through
18.
Now it's establish establishing vehicle
communication.
Okay. Checking condition of the vehicle.
Please wait.
Keep program success. Would you like to
program the next one?
Press yes if you have another one. Press
no if you don't have another one. So
it's telling us to press the start
button.
Okay, to turn it off.
Now it says to turn it on. So basically
for all Honda, this is how it is. Turn
it off. Turn it on.
So you might have to um
Okay. Are both the keys
keyless? Is indicator immobilizer light
off? Yes, it's off. We're going to press
yes. Now again, it's going to tell us to
shut it off. So, we're going to press
it.
Now, it says to turn it on. Okay. Now,
now you're going to have to press it
twice to turn it on every time you press
it. So, press it twice to turn it off
and once, excuse me, press it twice to
turn it on and once to turn it off. As
you guys can see, the registration is
complete. Okay, turn it off. Press it
once to turn it off. Now, don't put your
foot on the brake, okay? Like, do not
start the actual vehicle. It just wants
you to put it in accessory mode. As you
guys can see, excuse me, it's
programmed. The remote works. Everything
works perfectly. Um, please don't forget
if you guys like this video and helped
you out, subscribe to the channel. Join
our members only. And once again, this
is programming a smart key to a 2016 and
up Honda Civic using our Autel IM 608
Pro.
This is Mikey's Automotive. Thank you
guys so much. Till next time, you guys.